In Brazil, a crowd of 1.4 million protest against government corruption in Sao Paulo,...
...demanding the impeachment and ouster of leftist president Dilma Rousseff.
Twenty-two were killed in a beach town in Ivory Coast...
...by an al-Qaeda terrorist attack.
President Alassane Ouattara visited the shell-shocked city...
...to express his condolences.
In Turkey, an explosion in Ankara killed at least 34,...
...the second bomb in a month,...
...and officials say the suspected bomber...
...had links to the Kurdistan Workers' Party.
The US Navy's guided missile destroyer USS Barry arrives in Japan...
...in response to recent projectile launches by North Korea.
And finally from the US, pro and anti-Trump protesters...
...demonstrate in West Chester, Ohio...
...ahead of his scheduled campaign rally at the Savannah Center.